tom pelicero what a heck of a day he and
my colleague ian rappaport had on behalf
of all of us
at nfl network nfl media group he's the
one who tweeted this i saw his tweet
during the commercial break
i said out loud i'm like whoa i'm like
wait what and then you looked and you
saw that
uh reporting that the broncos had uh
acquired
russell wilson from the seahawks tom
pelisaro back here on the rich eisen
show how you doing tom
i'm doing well rich how are you i'm
doing all right so let's just dive right
into it uh the origin of this how'd it
start
what do you got
really these conversations between the
seahawks and broncos had been going on
for weeks and it heated up last week at
the scouting combine when
george payton and john schneider met
face to face and really began to talk
about
the compensation you know it was really
about the seahawks for everything they
had said publicly that they had no plans
to trade russell that really meant
behind the scenes they were only going
to trade him if it was a
transformational type of deal they were
absolutely prepared to move forward with
russell wilson as their quarterback in
2022 they did not get that but the
broncos stepped up and when you look at
the compensation two number ones
including the number nine overall pick
two second rounders and three players
including a quarterback who's still
young uh that the seahawks liked coming
out in the draft a tight end and noah
phantom's pretty good and a guy in
shelby harris who's a you know got a
reasonable deal and was a pretty good
veteran uh defensive player it made
sense and it also sets up seattle now to
have
um you know the the collateral here to
go and make potentially another move to
go get their next quarterback so uh what
about the idea that the washington
commanders were going yolo and might
still be all over the league right now
for somebody like russell wilson's
caliber and made a better deal or or
offered a a i guess a richer deal maybe
they don't have the players to come back
what can you tell me about the idea of
maybe
denver being in the afc russell wanted
them what about that anything on that
front
it
it had a lot to do with where russell
wilson wanted to go he had a no trade
clause and there's a unique relationship
between
russell wilson and the seahawks where
you know throughout the course this
offseason he and pete carroll had had a
lot of conversations they were very open
and russell would talk about different
places he might like to go play
it's unusual to say the least that you
have that type of relationship but you
know on the short list of teams that he
wanted to go to was denver and so my
understanding was uh over especially in
in the last few days here as this became
very real russell was very excited about
the idea of going to the broncos being
able to play with some really good young
talent and really being able to get kind
of a reboot
on his career here so once the
compensation matched up it moved pretty
swiftly you know regardless of what any
other team might have offered russell
wilson needed to be all in on going to
that place and denver checked a lot of
the boxes that he was looking for so why
why does this have to happen
what happened here
what happened to this relationship
tom
yeah you know i think that it's
sometimes people can reduce things to
only one factor i think that all of us
who live here on planet earth know that
interpersonal relationships are
inherently complicated and that was
certainly the case with russell wilson
there had been so much transition when
you talk about you know the fact that i
believe russell wilson bobby wagner were
the only two players left from the super
bowl winning team that's the nature of
the nfl uh things had evolved russell
wilson still did have a supporting cast
there i mean there's plenty of
quarterbacks out there who would go you
know gosh this guy doesn't want to play
with tyler lockett and dk metcalf and
chris carson when he's healthy and you
know all those types of things you know
i'd go in there i'd play with those guys
but for us it was more complicated than
that he's always envisioned himself
as somebody who
is one of the greats and wants to be a
hall of famer and he wants to win super
bowls and he wants to win the mvp and
he's never even gotten an mvp vote and
you see how many different things the
seahawks did over the course of time
to try to give russell what he wanted
whether it was you know making deals and
wilson would regularly talk to the front
office every star player who became
available he wanted to bring those guys
in uh he had one of the most aggressive
gm's in john schneider who was always
trying to add
those missing pieces to the roster
but it's also a matter of you know they
played out they were going to be a
defense first run first type of team for
a long time under pete carroll he got up
to that hot start in 2020 where they
were throwing the ball
a lot more then he went through a turret
defenses changed a little bit how they
were playing the seahawks pete wanted to
get back to running so they weren't
turning the ball over so much and those
mvp hopes all that talk kind of went
away and that's not to say that he's got
an agreement now that nathaniel
hackett's gonna have him throw the ball
60 times a game i don't think that's
going to be it at all but it's an
opportunity right now for him to go to
the next thing and for the seahawks
there has to be some level
of fatigue
knowing that you went through all this
last offseason all the speculation and
all the questions and now this off
season the same thing was happening you
know this would never end it would
continue into the future and so once you
get the type of package that uh john
snyder and pete carroll thought would
help the team not just now but in the
big picture
it made a lot of sense for them to say
this is the right time to reboot even
though you've got a 70 year old coach in
pete carroll who has no interest in
rebuilding again they've got a lot more
assets now and i expect that they're
going to be aggressive to add pieces to
their team and try to win in 2022. i'm
going to be blunt tom pelicero since you
were saying like here on planet earth
interpersonal relationships are
difficult it sure sounds if i read
between the tea leaves that both sides
were sick of each other after all this
time
what would you say to that
you know again i'd say
pete and russ talked a lot in this off
season it wasn't as if this was some you
know cold shoulder thing where they
weren't on speaking terms anymore they
were angry at each other it just was you
know i mean it would be unusual but if
you know eventually if you know you're
you seem to have a good relationship
with your wife and you've been together
for 10 years and then you know every uh
every january february starts talking
about hey what if i was married to that
guy at some point you might go you know
what maybe you should be married to that
guy i mean there's i think that there's
just some of that where it's just that
relationship over time it didn't
necessarily fray it's not like these two
didn't like each other go back to the
the meaningless week 18 game that i
believe they won and those two are
jumping around together high fiving like
they're both highly competitive
individuals but it was time it was time
on a lot of different fronts and you
know once it made sense for the seahawks
to do the deal they weren't just going
to give them away russ wasn't going to
you know necessarily force his way out
it just everything lined up and once
that became the case
it became a no-brainer for everyone
involved to move forward because because
if you have you know a 33 year old who's
going to be 34 right after thanksgiving
right and this is the guy who's been
with your team
you drafted him you nurtured him you
gave him the opportunity boy did he make
the most of it did he ever make the most
of it um and he's so terrific in the
community which loves him he loves them
he's a walter payton man of the year
award winner because of it you don't let
those guys out of the building right you
grow old with them you you try again
with them you reload with them that's
the whole idea and the fact that this
hasn't happened here
based on the way that their relationship
started it's kind of stunning i'll be
honest with you uh you know like i i i
was there in new york when they won it i
was there in arizona when they lost it i
was there when they drafted him russell
wilson was one of the first guests of uh
the rich eisen show
uh season opening podcast in 2012. they
everyone was head over heels with each
other and it's kind of stunning that
that's the result
i'll be able to think of it this way too
if you're processing this from the
seahawks standpoint just from a you know
completely dispassionate uh emotionless
roster building standpoint you also have
a quarterback who's now into his 30s
which of course we've seen quarterbacks
play a lot longer than that but you know
they don't necessarily rely on their
mobility as as much of a factor as
russell wilson you know he goes in the
third round because people thought this
guy's not gonna be able to see he's five
foot eleven you're gonna have to design
a unique offense and the seahawks did an
unbelievable job of that uh over the
course of the decade being able to you
know play a certain way that fit russ's
strengths and he's a phenomenal
playmaker and that's not to say that
he's not going to go to denver and do
the same type of things but if you are
strictly evaluating a 30-something year
old player and you look at the last
let's call it 20 games russell wilson
has played it hasn't been as good
at the end of the 2020 season the second
half of that when the turnovers came and
um you know they got away from throwing
the ball as much as they had early in
the season and there were some you know
creative defensive minds out there guys
like brandon staley with the rams who
really played him different you know
kind of left certain areas of the field
open and took away the deep ball and
forced rust to be a precision passer
short to intermediate which is not
really his game he's very much a he's
always played in a vertical strike type
of an offense that seemed to have an
effect we saw that in the games against
the rams we saw it when
another um
you know really good defensive
coordinator patrick graham came in with
a plan
for the giants in a game where the
seahawks didn't play particularly well
then of course you have a couple of
injuries thrown in there that was
obviously a factor the finger was a
factor but the point being if russell
wilson came out and played the way he
has over the last 20 or so games again
in 2022
now what is the value to the rest of the
league in other words if you have a year
and a half of okay what was injuries it
was a coordinator change it was other
injuries on the team whatever you can
kind of explain that to yourself if it
becomes just two and a half years of not
high you know the highest level of
russell wilson that we've seen that's
gonna impact what you can get for them
in a trade so you you figure this is the
maximum value we probably can get two
ones two twos three players i mean
that's that's a lot and not to mention
the fact that even if those players
don't work out they walk in free agency
you get cop picks coming back it
it made sense for what the what the
seahawks were trying to accomplish here
tom pelicero from nfl media group here
on the rich eisen show what is seattle's
planet quarterback now short long term
is it just start drew lock or
do they look in the draft do they um
what hope deshaun watson clears
everything what do you got for me on
that front i would i would say right now
all options are on the table for the
seahawks they did like drew lock coming
out in the draft i know that for a fact
several years ago obviously he's been
inconsistent which was kind of the knock
on him at missouri too but big arms
super athletic tall guy all that stuff
had some unfortunate injuries but you
know there might be something there and
they'd like to see what it is uh the
draft is certainly an option i don't
know that it's gonna make sense to take
somebody at number nine but you have the
flexibility uh with those additional
picks now to move around uh in the draft
and i would expect that they're going to
be in on the trade market you know the
desean watson situation and he continues
to
face serious allegations of sexual
misconduct
this is coming to a head legally
speaking over the next several days
because on friday
the district attorney in harris county
texas is going to present her case to
the grand jury grand juries in texas can
move pretty quickly so you could
potentially have an answer even on
friday uh but if not that then by next
week in terms of whether there's going
to be any criminal charges against him
his civil deposition also scheduled for
friday uh his attorney rusty harden his
name i'm sure you've heard a lot through
the years uh is advising him to uh
invoke the fifth amendment just because
you don't want somebody testifying in a
civil case while even active criminal
case but once the criminal case and you
have clarity on that that can trigger a
lot in terms of the civil cases getting
resolved and then it'll be in the hands
of the nfl
there's not enough quarterbacks we all
know that we also know the seriousness
of the allegations involving deshaun
watson i would fairly say
that considering the fact there were
multiple teams last year
both before training camp in training
camp and again at the trade deadline who
are willing to offer three first-round
picks and more for russ for desean
watson
you're going to find a market again and
the texans will be able to get
substantial value for so whether that's
seattle whether that's carolina with
that someplace else i do anticipate
you're going to see deshaun watson be
traded
this time around that's going to be a
key name in this entire picture for the
nfl well seattle certainly has more
draft capital now than they did at this
point yesterday so
um they're in a better position for that
but you know they might
if the if this doesn't get cleared
before the draft they'll have to use
that draft capital i mean the clock is
clearly ticking on on so many fronts on
that
um tom pelisaur here on the rich eisen
show before i let you go denver must be
over the moon they must be
everybody you speak to from the broncos
must be
out of their minds over the moon right
now certainly because you could make the
case the afc west is the deepest
quarterback pool in the nfl best
division at that position um and they've
now got somebody who can go toe-to-toe
with everybody in that spot right
it was the priority of the entire
offseason they feel like they've got a
foundation they've got good receivers
jerry judy cortland sutton they got a
youngsted running back in javonte
williams they've made a lot of progress
in terms of solidifying the offensive
line patzertan looks like a young star
on defense they probably need to add
another pass rusher i'd expect that they
try to address that in free agency
you know bradley chubb can stay healthy
he's still a really really talented
player they got a lot of pieces but they
they needed the quarterback and so
absolutely
they expect they're going to be able to
compete right now they were going to
swing big aaron rodgers russell wilson
those were the two priorities i got the
sense in recent weeks that
russell wilson may actually have been
plan a just because of you know with
aaron rodgers you don't know how long is
he actually going to play are you going
to do the retirement dance every year if
you bring him in with russell you're
hoping that he's going back he's gonna
be healthy he's gonna be the russell
wilson would see in the past and you may
have your quarterback for the next five
to
ten years so absolutely a huge day for
the broncos and let me also roots really
quickly clarify something because i
heard the caller before i came on asking
about why
you couldn't wait a day for bobby wagner
what i am told on that with the seahawks
releasing him was
this was going to happen it was going to
happen probably toward the end of this
week but after the russell wilson trade
bobby wagner actually contacted the
seahawks to ask you know what's
happening here the seahawks felt that it
was appropriate for them to grant him
his release so he can uh immediately
have a chance to sign up how about that
do you think bobby wagner goes to denver
what about vaughn
i don't know it's early on bobby wagner
but let's start there i would expect
that he's going to to have a market
von miller
is unbelievable as it seems and seemed
when he was traded away
i do believe that that will be a
consideration the possibility he heads
back to denver and listen that's this is
the type of thing that russell wilson
has always wanted he's always wanted to
be the the lebron james of the nba the
tom brady bring guys in everybody go and
play on the super team they got a lot of
good players in denver but to the extent
that russell wilson can i would expect
him to be a very active recruiter as he
was for years in seattle and it'll be
fascinating to see you know just exactly
how everything else flows from a roster
building standpoint as they get ready
for the 2022 seat tom great stuff
great job um let's talk uh early next
week in the middle of the frenzy as we
call it on the network so thanks for the
call
sounds great right now i got it tom
pellicero follow him on twitter i do
that's how i found out about the russell
wilson trade
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here